what's up ketchup crew welcome to the
weekly ketchup on YouTube where we bring
you the biggest news of the week in
movies and TV and this week we're taking
a look at what we already know about
Jurassic world Dominion and what we
could expect in a Sonic the Hedgehog
sequel plus we're handing out golden
tomato awards for our fan vote
categories so let's do this
it's time to get prehistoric because the
official title for Jurassic world 3 has
been revealed and production has begun
so let's take a look at what we already
know about the movie right now on the
kitchen the third and final installment
in the Jurassic world reboot slash
sequel trilogy is scheduled for a June
2021 release and now it officially has a
title courtesy of director Colin
Trevorrow on Twitter and it's called
Jurassic world um and if you're
wondering what Dominion means because I
literally had no idea thankfully Chris
Pratt saved us a trip to dictionary.com
with an Instagram post that contains the
words meaning plus he use it in a
sentence writing quote man's attempt to
establish dominion over nature we still
haven't caught on in this case nature
means dinosaurs and he fully pulled that
sentence from dictionary com what could
go wrong Dominion will round out the
trilogy that includes tomorrow's fresh
Jurassic world from 2015 and director
JAV Yoona's not so fresh Jurassic world
falling Kingdom from 2018 although that
one did make one point three billion
dollars hence another film but really
another fitting title for this new one
could have been Jurassic Park 6 as it
will bring together these three original
stars from 1993 certified fresh' first
film Jurassic Park cue the theme song
[Music]
that was totally my ringtone forever now
Jeff Goldblum wait can we get the right
picture up here for this part
Jeff did make a cameo in fawn kingdom
and both Sam Neill and Laura Dern were
in 2001's Jurassic Park 3 but they
haven't all been together since the
original and this time they'll join the
franchise's current star is Chris Pratt
and Bryce Dallas Howard also returning
from past Jurassic films are joseph
mazzello the kid from the 90s movies
along with BD wong and his evil
scientist character omar sy and jake
johnson you know for a little comic
relief it's in the king as far as where
this film could go with the story it's
unclear at this time if they will
actually move away from the formula of
introducing yet another bigger more
lethal dinosaur but after all that has
worked in the past probably not a good
idea but to get a little more specific
Trevorrow has described Dominion as a
science thriller dallas howard said it
will bring the entire saga together and
pratt suggested in an interview with MTV
News that the film will have a little
bit of a time jump after the events of
fallen Kingdom where dinosaurs were let
loose in the United States and to help
fill in that gap between films is last
year's battle at big rock it was a short
film from Toronto and co-writer Emily
Carmichael the same writing team for
Dominion you can actually find a 10
minute film on YouTube which features a
family whose camping trip is rudely
interrupted by an epic dinosaur battle
don't you say it when it happens plus it
gives us a look at what humans and
dinosaurs coexisting actually looks like
and let's just say I'm happy I don't
have to dodge a triceratops on the way
to work you know
my friends well friends after one
complete redesign and a couple hundred
million dollars at the box office
Sonic the Hedgehog is officially a hit
and with all the gold rings pointing to
sequel let's talk about what we could
see in around two right now on to catch
up
Sonic the Hedgehog is currently fresh at
64 percent on the tomato meter with a
more impressive audience score of 93
percent and after earning the best
opening ever for a video game movie
Sonic's worldwide box office total has
now sped through 200 million and it's
still going go on about how amazing I am
that success paired with a couple of mid
credit scenes from the movie most likely
means a sequel or better yet a movie
franchise is no doubt in the works
undermount right fYI there are spoilers
ahead so beware when it comes to what we
can expect from a sequel the first thing
would be thankfully hopefully more Jim
Carrey
in the first mid-credits scene at the
end of Sonic carries dr. Robotnik is
seeing 87 days later on the mushroom
planet and looking much more like the
villain we know and love from the video
game and from what Jim told us when we
talked to him a while back he's excited
about where the character is headed what
he's gonna evolve you know the plans to
evolve him is really and the other
mid-credits scene introduced us to none
other than miles per hour
aka tails the pilot a mechanical prodigy
is a friend and sidekick to Sonic and is
always flying around with that awesome
double tail and he just so happened to
show up in the sequel to the original
Sega Genesis video game so it's like
sequel kismet for really we all saw this
coming right and exactly why tails
showed up and is in such a hurry to find
Sonic along with what dr. Robotnik has
planned next good very well be driving
storylines in a potential sequel awesome
another character we could see pop up is
fan favorite knuckles from the third and
fourth Sonic Sega games a scene from
early in the movie showed Sonic fleeing
to earth after an attack by tribe of a
kid
which is the same species as knuckles
coincidence and based on what we know
storylines similar to the games where
knuckles was originally pitted against
Sonic by dr. Robotnik before they joined
forces to take on the villain would
definitely make sense here right I know
you can't talk back but drop a comment
so I'm not up here talking to myself
[Music]
plus if this does become a film
franchise we got to think or at least
hope that Shadow the Hedgehog will make
an appearance at some point the
archrival of Sonic was created by dr.
Robotnik as the ultimate life-form and
it seems like the perfect opportunity to
get another mega star into the vo booth
now speaking of casts along with carries
interest in returning Ben Schwartz who
is the voice of Sonic has said that he's
definitely on board especially if the
studio finally uses his version of the
classic Sega Genesis startup which he
recently did just for us
Sega there will no doubt be some new
faces or voices as well like the rock
I mean after his name was referenced in
a trailer back in December the rock
tweeted out his love for the sonic
character and he was offered a cameo
from the film's director Jeff Fowler on
the spot cuz you know that's what
happens when you're rich and famous that
cameo never happened but if fans on
Twitter get their way I mean the rock
will be joining the franchise as
knuckles and we all know what happened
last time fans got together to request a
change for this movie and it's worth
noting that tails was voiced at the end
of the movie by colleen o Shaughnessy
who currently does the character in the
sonic video game world but with a big
budgets equaling with a bigger name
could be a possibility get any work done
on my matter transporter with all these
distractions and while a sequel is not
yet confirmed and therefore no
production schedule has been set it is
fun to speculate that the untitled
animation project on Paramount scheduled
for July 22nd 2022 could very well
become Sonic 2 just trying to put two
and two together here that's a lot of
two's good time and now back to the 21st
annual golden tomato Awards here's your
host and as Perez well we made it
friends after weeks of voting for the
golden tomato award fan categories the
results are in and the suspense is
killing me so let's take a look at the
golden winners right now on the ketchup
kicking things off is the fan favorite
film of 2019 and no it's not parasites
whooping in for this
it's Avengers endgame the certified
fresh' blockbuster has an audience score
of 90% and thanks to the audience's
money it went on to become the highest
grossing film of all time that's a lot
of money bringing an entire saga to a
close isn't easy especially in this day
and age where everyone hates everything
but overall fans were pretty happy with
its conclusion plus the film helped set
up the MCS highly anticipated phase 4
which runs through 2021 and includes six
more feature films and a number of new
TV series on Disney Plus to which I say
hallelujah before we're done we still
have one promise to keep
and speaking of Disney Plus the fan
favorite TV show of last year was the
mandalorian the certified fresh' eight
episode season has a very impressive
audience score of 93% and I'm pretty
sure the Internet's favorite meme baby
Oda has a lot to do with that there are
a number of other characters in the
mandalorian that fans just can't get
enough of as well like Tycho itt's IG 11
Nick Nolte squeal he has spoken and of
course Jason Sudeikis as bike scout
trooper number one didn't know about
that one did you
as far as the fans favorite actor
category this was pretty much a two-way
race between joaquin phoenix and adam
driver with joaquin taking on the golden
tomato in the end
unlike driver phoenix only had one
credit to his name for 2019 but it was a
big one
I mean his portrayal of Arthur Fleck and
Joker won him all kinds of awards
including an Oscar and now this can I
personally deliver this one home no and
well we broke down some of the top
nominees for this category in a past
episode David on Facebook said Joaquin
Phoenix actually gave me chills with
that Joker cackles which I say Sam
Davidson
when it comes to the fan-favorite
Actress category Scarlett Johansson
didn't just win she had the most
lopsided victory of anyone earning four
times more votes than the next closest
actress but it's not surprising because
she slayed 2019 I mean we saw ScarJo in
the previously mentioned Avengers and
game and then she went on to star in
both marriage story and Jojo Rabbit
earning Best Actress and Supporting
Actress Oscar nominations before those
performances her first Oscar nom ever
and she got nom twice I'm gonna start
saying it nom and guess what she could
very well be winning this award again
next year because her own Black Widow
Marvel movie will be here on May 1st so
I'm gonna talk like grown-ups and
finally for the first time in 21 years
of doing the golden tomato Awards it is
time to hand out the golden Year award
the golden era work this is a big deal
you guys this one honors people who
appeared in or created some of the
year's best movies and TV shows and the
winner is duh Keanu Reeves Keanu Reeves
here I'd like to thank Ron tomatoes and
the golden tomato Awards and my thanks
to you the fans for the golden year
award that's pretty cool little wacky
but very cool his 2019 credits include
the certified fresh' trio of John wick
chapter three Parabellum which also
killed at the box office plus Toy Story
4 as the amazing Duke kaboom and Netflix
is always be my baby and let's not
forget as Kristoff on Facebook pointed
out Keano became a legend this year
thanks to the internet and also he
brought his mom to the Oscars so he
deserves this war and walk Kiana's 2020
is also shaping up to be pretty big with
projects like Bill and Ted based music
and the spongebob movie we're all just
pretty much waiting for Keano day on May
21st 2021 I'll bring the confetti and my
seven-layer dip I made out of sage and I
am the same all right friends thank you
for tuning in to the weekly catch up on
YouTube make sure to Tad's the subscribe
button and notification bell you know
what to do so you don't miss any future
episodes of the show as always I'm nas
Prez and we'll see you next week
[Music]